FINALLY, IT'S GRADUATION SEASON,
WHICH MEANS IT'S TIME
TO START PAYING OFF
A LIFETIME OF DEBT
FOR AN EDUCATION
THAT WON'T HELP YOU
MAKE ANY MONEY.
SO WHO BETTER THAN MY FANS,
WHO'VE ALREADY BEEN BEATEN DOWN
BY LIFE,
TO DISPENSE SOME FREE ADVICE
IN A SEGMENT CALLED
"WORDS OF TWISDOM."
"WORTH IT?"
"HI, I'M DAN TOSH."
TWISDOM.
"NEVER PUSH.
"IF IT ISN'T COMING OUT,
PULL YOUR PANTS UP
AND COME BACK LATER."
"DON'T TAKE PROFESSOR MILLER.
"[bleep] YOU, MILLER,
YOU SMUG ASSHOLE."
HA-HA!
MILLER!
TWISDOM.
"ONE: BEFRIEND A COWORKER
NAMED BRIAN.
"TWO: MAKE SURE
BRIAN IS WEAKER THAN YOU.
THREE: BLAME EVERYTHING
ON BRIAN."
"IF EVERYONE HAS AIDS,
THEN NO ONE HAS AIDS."
THAT'S SOME DEEP TWISDOM.
I THINK THAT'S SAFE TO TRY.
HAS ANYONE DONE THAT?
REALLY?
GET THE [bleep] OUT OF HERE.
TWISDOM.
GOOD LUCK TO THE CLASS OF 2014.
AND TRY NOT TO SUCK
LIKE THE CLASS OF 2013.
GOOD NIGHT,
AND CONGRATULATIONS